this may look like something out of a
horror film but it's actually a glass
worm
it's the larval form of a very common
lake insect called the phantom itch and
it's evolved kind of a horrific way to
catch a zooplankton these centimeter are
so long worms ambush their prey with
long articulated bristles that rapidly
unfurl into a catching basket recently
researchers discovered exactly how this
capture mechanism works they were using
high-speed video to study the
interactions between glass worms and one
of its main prey items water fleas also
known as Daphnia they found that many
bristles prevent the prey from escaping
including long upper lip hairs that fan
out sideways during the glass worm
attack other researchers had doubted
that these lip hairs could move because
they lack muscle but they might be
powered by the pressure of internal
fluids these videos shot at up to 8,000
frames per second also allowed the
researchers to time the attack the
bristles reached their target in just 14
milliseconds one of the fastest known
strikes out there for comparison the
mantis shrimp takes just four to eight
milliseconds the record-holders trap-jaw
ant's and trap jaws spiders attack in
less than one millisecond after the
glass worm has its prey safely and
snared it needs around 40 more
milliseconds to retract and then swallow
the prey but as you can see from this
real-time footage
[Music]
that's still pretty fast
[Music]
[Music]